[Music]
what's happening there reject nation i'm
james this is my co-host mason hawkins
how are you doing red hot comic book
movie news shooting up your butthole
i don't i think we can say maybe we'll
see hey guys we got some bad news but
maybe okay news maybe whatever news for
a lot of people it's really bad news and
i wanted to talk about it today it's
involving uh director john watts this
story broke yesterday hour today of the
time of filming it enter the twilight so
guys
time travel
videos in advance yeah so i wanted to
talk about uh how spider-man director
john watts has quit the fantastic four
movie something else came out online
that i wanted to touch on about john
krasinski replacing john watts in the
director's seat that's gonna be fun john
watts did put out a statement saying
making three spider-man films was an
incredible and life-changing experience
for me
i'm eternally grateful to have been part
i'm worried i got a booger in my nose do
i
don't certain turn to face me
i'm eternally grateful to have been a
part of the marvel cinematic universe
for seven years um hopefully we'll work
together again it's interesting to put
it that way i'm hopeful we'll work
together again so nothing else in the
pipeline nothing about another
spider-man four and i can't wait to see
the amazing oh my god spider-man easter
egg amazing vision oh my god one
division we're fantastic for brought to
life multiverse of quotes right here and
then uh kevin feige said something else
kevin feige collaborating with john on
the spider-man films has been a true
pleasure we were looking forward to
continuing our work with him to bring
the fantastic four into the mcu but
understand and are supportive of his
reasons for stepping away we are
optimistic that we will have the
opportunity to work together again at
some point down the road see sometimes
when you put this stuff in writing i get
so curious to know what is the tone of
this
what is the body language collaboration
with john the spider-man films yeah true
pleasure well you know like they're both
saying you know hopefully down the road
will work together again so it doesn't
sound like they've ended on bad blood in
fact deadline this is not not a quote
here but deadline did say in their
article nothing sinister oh my god
senator six nothing sinister here watts
just needs a break from the superhero
realm after completing the spidey
trilogy with tom holland and zendaya i
totally get that like the russo brothers
they had to stop after end game john
watts you know he me the first thing i
think he did before he got this movie
was like the movie cop
just like a small thriller he does have
another movie in the works i believed
with apple studios that's supposed to
start george clooney and brad pitt and
it's going to be even bigger than
spider-man
yeah the biggest crossover every
celebrity is going to be in it when you
commit like 10 years of your life to
filming one specific story i completely
understand when someone goes you know
what maybe i don't want to take on the
pressure revitalizing fantastic four a
franchise that just does not seem to do
well when translating from comic book to
film i believe marvel studios can do it
it's just there is more pressure on it
to start that process all over again to
go from i just redid spider-man it went
great it's one of the biggest movies
ever maybe i should take a break for a
while and leave on a bit of a high note
to start with fantastic four i could
just imagine what the pressure would
feel like to go the last couple
franchises didn't do so well this one
has to work this one has to be good
finally in the mcu yeah
this needs to be perfect at all cause
yeah and knowing the filming process of
how no way home went down too every film
usually has constant rewrites but they
go in with a whole different
variable of rewrites which is like we
don't know the ending yeah but we have a
lot of moving parts and pieces we have
to remove plot lines we got to put stuff
back in we got actors we don't have
access to
all sorts of craziness from the past
yeah so to go through the upheaval
battle of putting one of those together
again from
that sounds it does sound daunting and i
get why you want to re-center yourself
and just go back to yeah this is why i
love filmmaking and i think the two if
you look at the progress of the mcu
spider-man films it took until the third
one i think a lot of people would agree
for john watts's voice as a director to
really start to feel like it's informing
how the movie is shaped and is moving
and you know the committee is involved
with all of them but the third one
easily felt like the one most authored
by him and i feel like the fantastic
four movie probably puts a director in a
position where they have to again
because of all that baggage from the
past because of people's collective
memory of all that it doesn't seem like
you would have as much room to be free
and to you know really indulge your
cinematic instincts and expertise
whereas you know two i think it's got to
be enriching i think for any filmmaker
who's just spent a decade doing a
character as big as this also having to
answer for the past of that character
and years and years worth of legacy i
think you need to leave and go collect
some other inspirations and stretch your
legs out a little differently and then
yeah come back and i mean he he did no
way home if he wants to come back
they'll make it happen yeah yeah yeah
yeah
the ability to slap from the director of
spiderman no way home on any trailer
means money of course of course of
course yeah that's a great point now
let's talk about who could possibly
replace him a lot of people felt from
the beginning that otto had been paid in
reid the one who helmed the ant-man
films and i do think peyton reed would
be a fantastic choice all puns intended
however there was a tweet
by the greatest leaker of them all ha ha
look at toby this is toby mcguire nick
that's right that's his main claim to
fame john gambia he put this out here
and uh twitter's been running away with
it he says i'll say it
i'll say it
finger wave
john krasinski has agreed
to direct fantastic four and that's the
real reason why we didn't say why real
reason john watts stepped down [ __ ]
promised him another juicy mcu film
later if he agreed to go along with the
bs i just need a break excuse i mean i
believe that i need a rival
now before proceeding forward
a little bit later he did say i thought
it was clear but since a couple people
are asking this is not a report this is
my guess
fair enough
i however the way you phrase that
inside information and being like that's
the real
reason why because it's one thing if
like i say that [ __ ] but it's another
thing when with someone who does have
more industry insider information did do
something with some photos for a
previous film and then had to go here's
why i think it's fake and probably
favorite yeah yeah yeah he didn't try
taking this tweet down
oh my god can't be actually deleted the
tweet if you definitely did the tweet
does that mean that was actually
something real is he's trying to cover
his tracks what is going on here
what is going on here odds are probably
doesn't know even though when i go
online i'm like a lot of people are
going i bet john campio actually knows
something and he's now he's trying to
like cover it you know well this is the
great thing about all these leaks and
the andrew garfield stuff and yada yada
yada is now i feel like up until
anything comes out it could be anyone's
game you know someone could be guessing
properly someone could actually know
somebody could just be throwing out a
theory i mean i think it's funny that he
led with i'll say it because that just
implies that it's either gonna be a hot
take or a piece of info he was sitting
on yeah instead of like i'm accustomed
to hearing john put his opinion out
there and speculating so i don't feel
like i'll say it really is necessary if
that's what you're doing and you don't
want people to be confused by that yeah
but yeah i mean it's a decent theory and
hey if john watts really didn't want to
leave that seems like the absolute most
gracious way to be like yeah sure john
take it over because no one's gonna be
happy that i stayed if they hear you
once yeah
maybe i mean i think john watts would
have been fantastic but krasinski who's
done like his most notable directing
gigs is like his most popular ones are
horror films i think maybe the theory
comes into mind of john krasinski would
star in it as mr fantastic only if he
could direct it you know which i would
be cool with i'd be excited i'll be
honest you know a lot of people want
john krasinski to direct this and
there's nothing i've seen in a quiet
place that makes me go you'd be great
for example that's fantastic for
granted i don't know the other films
he's done so for me i only have to go
off of a quiet place yeah i'm sure he'd
do a just a really fine job either way
regardless i want john krasinski as mr
fantastic make it happen make it happen
mark cowards don't be a [ __ ] the way
you've done john watts dirty yeah yeah
well you shipped him in the back that's
right you threw him overboard threw him
under that zinske yeah you jerks you're
a bunch of jerks marvel signed him on in
twenty twenty years
why would a director wanna break
especially after working on this for
over a year and being involved in the
biggest whirlwind of media frenzy over a
movie in a long time a bunch of bs yeah
there's no way he would want to break
money talks maybe guys who would you
want to take over for directing
fantastic four
mel gibson
edgar wright no
i'm pretty sure mel gibson is definitely
mel gibson
get him to play mr francis
that'd be great or doctor doom or doctor
both actually be a good doctor dude he
would be a good doctor doom
that's the kind of doctor
all right see you guys
you